antes de arrancar quiero hacerles una
pregunta les pido por favor que me
colaboran en diferentes instancias de mi
charla quienes de ustedes se encuentran
actualmente en la búsqueda laboral
activa o porque se encuentran
desempleados o porque quieren realizar
un cambio laboral o si no son ustedes si
conocen a alguien que está en esta
situación por favor les pido si me
ayudan y levantan la mano
un poco más alto bueno hay varios de
ustedes que están en esta situación
generalmente a lo largo de nuestra vida
muchos nos encontramos en diferentes
instancias en esta situación de búsqueda
de trabajo y en cierta manera nos da un
poco de pánico pero los quiero llevar a
nuestra infancia cuando nosotros éramos
muy pequeños y recién empezábamos a
conocer el mundo empezábamos a fantasear
con esto de que queríamos ser cuando
seamos grandes y ahí empezábamos a tener
los primeros estímulos externos de
nuestro entorno y nos empezaron a
preguntar ellos mismos si con un cierto
mandato tácito que querés ser cuando
seas grande y ahí nosotros con toda
nuestra fantasía contestábamos bombero y
automáticamente venía un adulto que 'la
en algún momento somos nosotros ahora y
decíamos y porque no quiere ser médico
porque no estudias paramédico
y venían y preguntaban que crecer cuando
sea grande y yo contestaba veterinaria y
me decían y por qué no quieres ser
contador como tu papá
y en ese momento nos empezaban a
estimular con ciertas condiciones que a
nosotros después creíamos que no nos
impactaba
pero iban dejando huella y así desde ese
momento en adelante nuestra vida está
intervenida por nuestras experiencias y
vamos aprendiendo a medida que vamos
avanzando nuestros estudios y vamos
generando experiencias en otros entornos
sociales practicamos un deporte de
repente también nos encontramos
perteneciendo a un grupo religioso
generamos algún vínculo con una
organización civil de voluntariado vamos
adquiriendo herramientas experiencias
que van formando una valija de
herramientas con las que nosotros
salimos al mercado porque cuando salimos
al mercado nos salimos en blanco con
recién me recibí un título o 17 18 años
voy a buscar un primer empleo tenemos un
montón de recursos pero tenemos que
saber identificarlos
la idea de hoy es que podamos ampliar
esa valija de recursos y que podamos
salir mejor preparados al mundo laboral
y cuando digo mejor preparados es porque
hay estadísticas que demuestran que no
nos preparamos para buscar trabajo
recientemente se hizo una encuesta de
empleabilidad y esta encuesta determinó
que 5 de cada 10 personas que se
encuentran buscando trabajo no se
preparan para buscarlo lo hacen de mano
de manera aleatoria o intuitiva por lo
que su pensamiento le dicta que tiene
que hacer sin buscar información
de esas 10 personas las mismas 10
personas 7 cuando avanza en alguna
proceso de selección no se prepara para
la entrevista pero después no quedamos
seleccionadas y después ese trabajo no
era para nosotros y después salimos a
buscar culpables pero cuanto hubo de ese
proceso de en este proceso de
responsabilidad nuestra tenemos
posibilidad de intervenir en los
procesos de selección podemos tomar
acción entonces ahí es donde yo los
invito a poder trabajar las
oportunidades que se presentan desde el
reconocer esas oportunidades acá hago un
punto muy importante no es
identificarlas si no hay poder
conocerlas muy bien para que estas
oportunidades juegan a nuestro favor
entonces los invito a pensar lo
siguiente si ustedes o algún familiar
suyo de su entorno se encuentran
actualmente decidiendo qué estudiar una
vez que termine la secundaria bueno los
invito a que investiguen tienen que
investigar qué pasa en el mundo rompan
los mandatos es muy importante que
ustedes puedan
si lo que están por elegir como sus
estudios es lo que quieren hacer en un
futuro no muy lejano qué pasaría si
ustedes terminan dentro de tres años una
carrera de pregrado o una carrera
universitaria dentro de cuatro cinco
seis o siete y se dan cuenta que todo
eso que ustedes estudiaron ya lo hace
hoy la inteligencia artificial sería muy
triste y en algún punto se sentirían
frustrados por otro lado también sería
muy importante que si todavía no
pudieron estudiar una carrera no se
desalienten lo importante es que sepan
que tienen oportunidades
hoy en día nosotros los seres humanos
cada vez queremos que nuestros problemas
cotidianos se resuelvan con mayor
facilidad y ahí es donde aparece la
oportunidad de poder estudiar un oficio
de poder emprender de manera
independiente y así generar
empleabilidad si actualmente se
encuentran desempleados y están un poco
frustrados porque no piensan en utilizar
esta profesión que tienen de base o este
oficio que adquirieron y desarrollarse
como profesionales independiente
y ofrecer ese servicio a la comunidad
hasta tanto puedan insertarse
laboralmente y por último si están
pensando en un cambio laboral los
felicito este es un momento porque si
hay algo o todavía no lo pensaron y lo
están pensando a partir de ahora si hay
algo con lo que no están conformes esto
quiere decir que no están cómodos y
tienen que salir de su zona de confort
entonces nosotros hoy estamos
aprendiendo qué cosas son importantes
tener en cuenta a la hora de buscar
trabajo y no podemos perder de vista que
el currículum vítae que son todas esas
herramientas que venimos trayendo desde
nuestra infancia son nuestra carta de
presentación tómenlo con seriedad
pero bueno como esto es una charla
motivacional no quiero ir con los no
escribir con los sí que tenemos que
hacer para buscar trabajo cuáles son los
tips la fórmula mágica para yo
insertarme laboralmente
bueno la mala noticia es que no hay
fórmula mágica yo les decía depende
mucho de nuestra actitud pero si hay
tips que podemos tener en cuenta el
primero es
yo les decía dedicarse a buscar trabajo
o sea que el trabajo sea un trabajo el
buscar trabajo sea un trabajo cuando por
lo menos una hora al día
tienen que ponerse en sus agendas una
hora al día para hacer esta tarea que
hoy les voy a contar ahora
si están trabajando fuera del horario
laboral si no están trabajando y están
buscando insertarse laboralmente le
pueden dedicar mucho más que una hora
porque ustedes se están dedicando a eso
los segundos tengo que investigar el
terreno en el que estoy tengo que
investigar el mercado cuando voy a salir
a buscar trabajo de qué me sirve tener
el mejor se ve si no sé a dónde lo voy a
enviar y este punto es fundamental donde
estoy ubicado geográficamente quiero
trabajar acá quiero trabajar
virtualmente que empresas instituciones
organismos públicos del tercer sector
hay según a donde yo me dediqué
hay en mi territorio bueno ingreso a la
web me fijo si hay una solapa donde supo
cargar mi cb si no lo hay puedo buscar
en la misma página web o por google que
está toda la información un mail de esa
empresa y hacerle llegar mi cb y algo
que ya no está tan utilizado porque la
verdad que la tecnología va hasta avanzó
bastante y las áreas de selección se
manejan todo de manera digital pero
pueden acercar el currículum a la
empresa oa la institución el currículum
físico
y otra cosa fundamental sigan las a las
empresas en las redes sociales las
empresas hoy están utilizando todo su
abanico de redes además de la web
facebook instagram linkedin y twitter
inclusive para postular sus búsquedas
entonces ahí ustedes no dejan su sede en
una base de datos para que en algún
momento lo llamen sino que directamente
se postulan a esa búsqueda que a ustedes
les interesa
habiendo recorrido ya el territorio y
todos los días tomarme el trabajo de
buscar trabajo claramente tienen que
desarrollar las herramientas para
buscarlo la primera herramienta como
hablábamos en el cb el cb es algo que
está muy cuestionado pero la verdad es
que todavía se sigue utilizando que
tiene que contener información precisa y
objetiva cuando alguien lea el
currículum de ustedes tiene que
imaginarse los a ustedes sin conocerlos
entonces que tienen que incluir sí o sí
datos concretos de contacto tienen que
poner su nombre y apellido fecha de
nacimiento un mail de contacto un
teléfono y donde residen mínimamente eso
está bien no hace falta más datos
personales más datos personales quizás
los van a los van a incorporar en una
segunda instancia en una entrevista que
tienen que incluir tienen que incluir su
formación que estudiaron no solamente lo
que es educación formal sino también
todas las actualizaciones que ustedes
fueron teniendo a lo largo de su carrera
cursos cortos
pero importante es que tengan que ver
con el lugar a donde ustedes están
postulando si no hace falta que pongan
que hicieron un curso de cocina si son
ingenieros industriales si después lo
pueden contar en la entrevista pero no
abulten el cb con información que no es
relevante y tienen que incluir cuáles
son sus habilidades principales que en
que se destacan ustedes el trabajo en
equipo se destacan en escucha activa son
personas que tienen capacidad de
análisis tienen que incluir esto porque
ya los de alguna manera les decía yo es
su presentación y lo fundamental es
tener bien clara la parte de trayectoria
laboral si ya tuvieron experiencias
previas tienen que siempre incluir en
qué lugar trabajaron en qué puesto
trabajaron desde cuándo y hasta cuándo y
si quieren pueden incorporar de una a
tres de las tareas más importantes que
hacían
con toda esta información no les tiene
que llevar más de dos carillas
yo veo mucho se ve hoy en día que tiene
mucho color mucho diseño valoración de
competencias pero cuando uno lo lee
carece de sustento
entonces yo los invito a que ustedes se
piensen como que es su carta de
presentación ya no se utiliza más en el
cb poner la primera hoja de caricia o de
nombre o quería currículum vítae no se
utiliza enviar una carta de presentación
diciendo me postulo a ustedes de a quién
corresponda me dirijo directamente es el
cb pero ese se ve tiene que ser de
impacto
dedicándonos todos los días un tiempo a
buscar trabajo habiendo recorrido el
mercado en el que estamos y teniendo
nuestro se ve listo nos puede pasar que
en el mientras tanto que buscamos
trabajo en relación de dependencia no lo
encontremos
entonces ahí tenemos que salir a
trabajar fuertemente las redes sociales
y salir ya sólo de las empresas y pasar
a las redes sociales con ese se ve que
ustedes hicieron lo tienen que trasladar
directamente a linkedin levantan las
manos cuando de acá no tienen perfil de
linkedin o no saben qué es
bueno todos tienen me alegro un montón
porque hace poco en un curso todos nos
dijeron que no tenían es muy importante
que se perfile esté actualizado inclines
una red social y laboral que
automáticamente cuando un selector está
viendo en nuestro se ve va a ver si lo
que yo tengo en mi email o en mi
computadora es exactamente lo mismo que
aparece en ese perfil nuevo primero a
facebook no va primero a instagram
porque aparte de esas redes sociales
tienen la particularidad de que pueden
no ser públicas lo primero a linkedin y
la verdad chicos muchas veces no dice lo
mismo eso es un primer factor en algunos
casos de descarte del perfil porque hay
incongruencia entonces actualiza en su
perfil de linkedin en el mismo momento
tienen que limpiar sus redes personales
de las profesionales ustedes no pueden
utilizar las redes personales para sus
contactos laborales porque sus redes
personales usted
por una disposición del mundo que los
rodea sus pensamientos sus ideologías
sus emociones días de crisis a veces con
el trabajo actual y está bien que tengan
ese espacio pero sus contactos laborales
no los deberían ver porque ustedes
laboralmente tienen otro perfil
entonces cuiden esas redes conozcan
cuáles son las novedades en cuanto a
portales de búsqueda en el lugar donde
están buscando ustedes trabajo cuáles
son los portales que más funcionan
carguen ahí sucede entren constantemente
para buscar cuáles son las oportunidades
laborales que hay y conozcan también en
las plataformas de redes sociales las
nuevas funcionalidades hace un par de
años facebook lanzó dentro de la red
social una solapa que es empleos o sea
que hoy las empresas que tienen página
de facebook pueden postular sus
búsquedas a través de facebook y ustedes
se pueden postular a través de facebook
muy pocos lo conocen y muy pocos lo
utilizan
conozcan todas las herramientas que hay
para postularse entonces ustedes van a
complementar el conocimiento que van a
tener del mercado y las empresas en las
cuales se quieren dirigir con los
portales en los cuales se pueden
justamente postular
y una vez que hagan esto si no consiguen
trabajo también pueden pensar en dos
opciones hablábamos de ser independiente
en algún punto bueno como profesional
independiente cada vez está más en auge
el ser freelance trabajar de manera
independiente la virtualidad lo aceleró
y para trabajar de manera independiente
yo tengo la opción de trabajar por
proyectos y hay plataformas para esto
hay plataformas que son portales de
búsqueda para personas que prestan
servicios por ejemplo por ghana por
ejemplo freelancer por ejemplo ni remoto
entonces ustedes ahí también cargan
sucede y les llegan ofertas para
trabajar en relación de independencia si
prestan un servicio por un tiempo
determinado y quizás hasta eso consiguen
otro trabajo y porque no como
profesional independiente ofrecer sus
servicios usted me dirán como creando
una marca
y ofreciendo quizás desarrollando un
emprendimiento no necesariamente
ofreciendo un servicio y también hay
portales para hacerlo todo el mundo sabe
cómo funciona el mercado libre o lx si
hay otros que se llaman lo cando segunda
segunda mano son diferentes portales que
uno puede utilizar para posesión
posicionarse como profesional
independiente hasta tanto conseguir
trabajo en relación de dependencia
en este sentido seguimos transitando un
camino donde de repente nos llaman por
teléfono y llegamos a la instancia de la
entrevista y yo les decía hay que
prepararse como nos podemos preparar
para enfrentar una entrevista laboral
bueno la primera recomendación es que
apenas reciban ese llamado validen bien
cómo va a ser la entrevista si va a ser
virtual si va a ser presencial validen
también quién los va a entrevistar es
muy importante que ustedes también
puedan preguntar en ese momento qué
duración va a tener la entrevista y algo
que es clave y que demuestra el interés
que tienen ustedes por ese trabajo
pregúntenle a la persona que los está
llamando si tienen su sede actualizada y
si no lo tienen pónganlo a disposición
fundamental si no van a ir a la
entrevista avisen si se van a bajar del
proceso avisen nunca saben cuándo van a
volver a buscar trabajo en el mismo
lugar por último muy importante cree en
redes de contactos nuevas si ustedes
están buscando nuevas oportunidades
tienen que ampliar su círculo social
aprendan un idioma practiquen un deporte
hagan otras actividades para generar
contactos distintos porque quizás ahí
está su oportunidad de trabajo y la
última que no es menor es nunca dejen de
capacitarse las competencias están
cambiando y tenemos que estar
constantemente actualizados en este
último punto quiero desmitificar tres
aspectos de la búsqueda de trabajo el
primero es que no nos contratan por
nuestras competencias técnicas nos
contratan por nuestras habilidades
conductuales nos contratan por nuestros
conocimientos y por nuestros
comportamientos saber saber hacer saber
estar si investigan cuáles son las
competencias del futuro a gilismo
dinamismo pensamiento creativo poder
aplicar la creatividad no sólo la
innovación y al mismo tiempo piensa
en cómo tiene que ser el trabajo en
equipo a futuro los puestos de trabajo
van a cambiar capaciten se porque dentro
de un par de años quizás ustedes se
tienen que encontrar en estudiando una
nueva carrera para mantenerse empleables
y el último acepta en la diversidad va a
ser la clave del trabajo en equipo y la
flexibilidad y adaptación en las
organizaciones todos en algún momento de
nuestra vida buscamos trabajo
para todo es un proceso crítico y es
difícil sí pero no nos peleemos con el
proceso ahora hacemos este proceso
trabajemos sobre el mismo nos
organicemos y piensen que para obtener
resultados diferentes tienen que hacer
las cosas de manera diferente muchas
gracias persigan sus sueños
[Aplausos]